disco delivers affordable science-backed
skin care treatments to your home the
Disco Starter Set helps guys fight oily
skin and razor burn and keeps your skin
hydrated I've had great results with it
you'll get 30 percent off at
letsdisco.com Pacman the link is down
below
let's start today with the latest on the
pandemic in the United States and around
the world then I want to look at the
question do any religions actually
prohibit vaccination for all of the talk
about I have a religious exemption from
being vaccinated what religions ban
being vaccinated if any we're going to
look at that in a moment now last week I
came to you and I said coveted cases are
down 53 percent in the U.S from their
Delta Peak deaths are down 33 percent in
the U.S from their Delta Peak that was
last week and we said what will the next
week look like well it's now next week
relative to last week and the numbers
are once again better let's look at
those numbers and see just how much
better the U.S average daily covid cases
are now down 59 from their Delta wave
peak of 167 000 a day the U.S now seeing
68 000 cases per day yes it's a crazy
number
but it's the lowest it's been since late
July and for now it's pointing down
rather than pointing up and that's a
good thing in terms of daily U.S deaths
the Delta wave Peak was all the way back
up to just the hair under 2 000 deaths a
day that is now down to about
1275 deaths a day of a tragic number but
a decline of 35 percent so both cases
and deaths declining in the last week
cases declining more than deaths on a
percentage basis okay what's the global
context what's happening globally well
globally cases are actually going back
up
this is being led by some specific
countries which I'll tell you about in a
moment but globally cases have gone up
it's not a big change but cases globally
were down to about 403 000 a day they're
now back up to 416 000 a day it's a
small change but it could be meaningful
it could mean one of two things number
one we could be seeing the start of
another wave with winter coming to the
Northern Hemisphere that's that's a
possibility
it could just be a blip uh we don't know
yet but this is being led by some
countries with major increases in cases
last week I'll give you some examples
the Czech Republic has gone from like
they were almost at zero that they had
150 cases a day
they're at 3 000 a day 150 to 3 000 a
day that's a huge spike in the Czech
Republic and when I tell you the other
countries where we're seeing increases
you'll start to notice a regional Trend
Hungary Poland Slovenia are seeing big
spikes Hungary went from 70 cases a day
to 2 000. Poland went from 150 cases a
day to five thousand Slovenia went from
60 cases a day all the way up to about
1750. just those few countries already
that's a major increase and you look at
the others Slovakia Croatia Ukraine all
seeing significant increases in cases so
it could be that area also big concerns
in the United Kingdom at one point last
week the United Kingdom had the highest
case rate I believe in the world now
stabilizing at a very bad number of 45
000 cases A Day in the UK that's all bad
so the question is is that coming to the
UK coming to the U.S rather we saw with
Delta that it started in Europe and then
we were just lagging behind I think it
was like six to eight weeks or something
like that so is what's happening in some
of these European countries now going to
be here in six or eight weeks we just
don't know yet you can find opinions
saying yes you can find opinions saying
no one view is we are going to see a
decline and we are get going to get to
sort of like endemic levels where you
get yourself vaccinated
um if you do or participate in indoor
events with a bunch of people maybe
everybody gets tested I've been to a
couple events including a birthday party
where that was the protocol that's one
of you we're getting down to that
endemic level
the other view is this is about to
explode as we head into winter in the
United States what do we know about the
U.S right now we know that vaccination
is basically flat at a very low level
we're doing about 800 000 vaccinations
per day with reports indicating that
there are more third doses in those 800k
than first doses that's very very bad we
know that we are believed to be very
close to vaccine approval for 5 to 11
year olds an FDA panel recommending that
approval yesterday and now we're just
waiting for broader approval it could be
that we start vaccinating 5 to 11 year
olds as soon as next Friday
um that's uh that that's something we're
following we know that schools where you
are not required to wear a mask are
seeing significantly higher coveted case
rates than those where you are so masks
continue to be relevant for those
unvaccinated kids
also knew the CDC is now saying that
some immunocompromised people
uh can and should get a fourth covered
shot that is not something that was uh
previously discussed in any great detail
and now the CDC is saying yeah it's not
just a third dose for some
immunocompromised people uh we should be
looking and even starting to do fourth
doses so we're going to follow all of
this case is down here
uh but increasing globally and the
question is are we headed for a very
dark winter or are we headed for a not
so bad winter with things being
essentially everything open
um some places with vaccine requirements
some places vaccine or testing
requirements
Etc as we've been seeing so we will
continue to follow it we'll see where we
are uh by next week we could either be
at 60 down from the Delta Peak or we
could start to see a turnaround which
would not be very good all right let's
talk about religious vaccine exemptions
you hear so often we allow religious
exemptions or I should be allowed to get
a religious exemption and then that
brings us to the question of
are there religions that ban vaccination
is it what what exactly are people
talking about what do they mean or do
they just mean I've decided it's my
personal religious belief now this is
not a debate over the validity of
religious exemptions we're examining are
there
anti-vaccine religions it's actually
pretty tough to find so let's go through
a few of the things we know
um a couple weeks ago I said you know
maybe Jehovah's Witnesses
um but then I heard from a Jehovah's
Witness actually two different Jehovah's
Witnesses who said we got the vaccine we
were told uh to get uh to take this
seriously nobody said anything in our
churches about not getting vaccinated so
the Jehovah's Witnesses I've heard from
have said no no we we got we got
vaccinated
um I said maybe Christian Science but
then I heard from a Christian scientist
who said actually David it's fine it's
just it's up to each individual person
but that being said there are reports
that the Church of Christ scientists
known as Christian Science
um is an anti-vaccine religious group so
upon further research it appears as
though it's sort of up to the local
Pastor to some degree now I know that no
matter what I say about this someone
will disagree but it the best assessment
that I have right now is that with
Christian Science it is not necessarily
anti-vaccine at the top level
but that there are individual uh
Christian Science pastors who are taking
positions against the vaccine now
PolitiFact looked at this and politic
PolitiFact uh found a few of what they
identified as anti-vaccine religions but
the context was that Dr Anthony fauci
had said there are precious few
religions that actually say you cannot
get vaccinated that was determined to be
mostly True by PolitiFact
um the summary is there are hundreds of
religions but in one tally about five
van ban vaccination
uh people must prove their stances based
on a sincerely held religious belief
employers must accommodate it but not if
it would impose an undue burden on
operations and recent Supreme Court
rulings indicate governments should seek
alternatives to mandate so what does
PolitiFact say
PolitiFact says
Vanderbilt University Medical Center's
review of immunization and religion
identified a small subset of Christian
faiths that oppose vaccination on
theological grounds there are five a
group that includes the Dutch Reformed
Church
of the firstborn Faith Assembly and End
Time Ministries this is not
comprehensive now it says many people
might instantly think of Christian
Scientists while many Christian
scientists rely on prayer for healing
the Christian Science Church offered
guidance to members on vaccines in 2019
and said for more than a century our
denomination has counseled respect for
public health authorities and
conscientious obedience to the laws of
the land including those requiring
vaccination church leaders impose no
decision on church members but they
encourage them to recognize the
seriousness of Public Health church
members are free to make their own
choices on all life decisions in
obedience to the law including whether
or not to vaccinate Protestant faiths
Islam Roman and Orthodox Catholicism
Judaism Hinduism Jainism Buddhism
Jehovah's Witnesses and more have no
prohibition against vaccination so what
is the bottom line on this entire
religious exemption thing the bottom
line is there are very few actual from
the top vaccine prohibitions there are
anecdotally individual pastors who will
rant and Rave in churches and say we're
not bringing the vaccine here it's the
mark of the beast this type of thing so
when we've seen that it's typically
typically a random individual
Evangelical Pastor in you know Georgia
or Ohio or whatever who is saying don't
get it it's bad bad bad and by the way
vote for Trump uh but that is an
individual Pastor it's not actually from
script scripture so I think the takeaway
here is we're not even getting into the
debate over the validity of religious
exemptions
California has made it very difficult to
even get one but what we are pointing
out is when someone says it's against my
religion we should ask more questions
and say okay well all right what is your
religion what is the scripture that says
it's against your religion now
in a purely empirical standpoint uh it
really doesn't make a difference whether
it's in scripture or not or whether it's
a pastor saying it or not like what I
mean by that is scriptures held up as
supposed holy texts
are just that supposed holy texts only
if you believe that religion it's sort
of like trying to impose what the Bible
says on someone who doesn't believe in
the Bible it's sort of like well I don't
I don't care what the Bible says because
it doesn't it doesn't apply to me I
don't care about that and in the same
way it's not really that different from
a random random Pastor saying we're not
getting vaccinated here don't get
vaccinated the vaccine is bad from a
validity standpoint but I think the main
takeaway is a lot of the people claiming
religious exemptions they're not really
based in anything other than maybe a
ranting pastor at their church so that's
what it is very tough to find actual
religious opposition to vaccination uh
take it for what it is and if you have
anything anecdotal to share about this
about your church or your community or
whatever find me on Twitter at dpacman I
would love to hear from you about it
one of our sponsors is Disco there are
so many different types of bogus skin
care products for men out there what you
really want to go with is just something
affordable effective and created by
dermatologists that's why we have disco
which delivers the science-backed
over-the-counter skin treatments that
dermatologists recommend to their
patients every day the Disco Starter Set
is a simple way to take care of your
skin in three quick steps the face
cleanser stick fights oily skin the
exfoliating face scrub prevents razor
burn and the face moisturizer keeps your
skin hydrated disco can also help with
ingrown hairs dry skin acne and other
things you just need 60 seconds a day
I've been using it for a while now I'm
seeing a noticeable difference maybe you
can even tell check out disco try out
the products for yourself you will like
the results and you'll get 30 off when
you go go to
let'sdisco.com Pacman or just enter the
code Pacman the link is down below I
don't know that I've mentioned before
that our program does depend on the
support of viewers and listeners to the
podcast people who watch clips on
YouTube or listen to us on the radio
watch on Free Speech TV or one of our
various television Affiliates and the
best way to support our program is to
sign up at joinpakman.com we have great
perks we recently did one of our viewer
Town Halls where our members get
priority in speaking to me we do an
extra show every day for our members and
so many other great things you can sign
up today at joinpakman.com all right I
want to follow up this Neil Cavuto thing
has gotten really really interesting
yesterday we talked about Fox News host
Neil Cavuto
literally begging his audience
supplicating saying get vaccinated stop
the politicization of vaccines and he
has been essentially ignored by his
entire network now Neil Cavuto is in a
particular Health situation Neil Cavuto
has had multiple sclerosis for quite
some time he had heart surgery he was
vaccinated when he recently got coveted
and he attributes having as mild the
case as he did
statistically he attributes it of course
it's all anecdotal individually but
statistically he attributes it to being
vaccinated so we looked yesterday at
multiple clips of him pleading with his
audience here is one such example as a
reminder to get us all on the same page
lost five million globally to this we've
lost nearly 800 000 in the U.S take the
political speaking points and toss them
for now I'm begging you toss them and
think of what's good not only for
yourself but for those around you if you
don't want to do it for yourself if you
think it's a pain in the ass I get that
right but think of others around you I
dare say people who experience this or
seen loved ones who've been affected by
this or have never died from this are
not judging the wisdom of mandates
they're wishing they got vaccinated and
they didn't I don't know so we suspected
that based on the reaction from other
shows which was to say nothing about
this shows on Fox to say nothing about
this and just keep hammering about
vaccine mandates and protests and all of
this different stuff
we suspected it that his audience might
not like this and in fact that's the
case so yesterday uh there were some
responses to Neil Cavuto begging his
audience about the vaccine shared and
some people in his audience want him
dead now I
I received death threats all the time on
this show and and many people in media
do
um but it's interesting that his own
right-wing audience which he has fed
he's built this monster over the last
however many 20 plus years that he's
been on Fox News I think
um they very quick the people that want
me dead are never people that were on my
side
um the people that seem to want Neil
Cavuto dead are people that were fine
with him they were viewers of his show
so let's take a look at it he shared
some of these um yesterday
uh we got uh TJ who also emails it's
clear you've lost some weight with all
this stuff good for you but I'm not
happy with less of you I want none of
you I want you gone dead kaput fanet get
it now take your two-bit advice deep six
it and you wow that's uh rather harsh
Neil so
uh Vince tweets hey guys I bought a new
car after being told it was the best
then I blew up after I left the car lot
so now I'm begging everyone to please
buy the same car sorry I was just
pretending to be Neil Cavuto so I guess
that the implication is Cavuto only
wants other people to get the vaccine
because he got it and the vaccine is
terrible so he wants other people to
experience the same bad stuff I mean
it's crazy it's bizarre which I think is
uh being a little uh sarcastic there in
that last tweet
you think a little bit a little bit a
little bit a little bit okay I know you
love that the cringy nature of the
segment is not lost on me by the way
another tweet political fact PolitiFact
bias Neil Cavuto has been fully
vaccinated for months and has been a
vocal Advocate about the safety and
efficacy of covet vaccines publicly and
repeated repeatedly on air this is not a
new position for him which is true Neil
this is not a new position and that's
kind of what we were stressing in all
services look we're this is something
from the very beginning I've been saying
that I think the better part of valor is
if you haven't been vaccinated it might
be a good idea for you to get vaccine I
understand those for religious personal
reasons don't want it but I understand
also the numbers now remember we dealt
earlier with the religious thing there's
almost no religions that actually ban
vaccination and the ones that do are not
prominent religions for the most part in
the United States or we do get
vaccinated the bigger the drop in in
cases absolutely yeah didn't fall on all
receptive ears like no clearly not I got
another one for you from ignis uh
aspiring to Aspire tweets Cavuto is the
Tigger of Talking Heads a head full of
fluff just not the not cool like Tigger
and I think for the record we had our
fact Checkers look at this I think she
is actually referring making the
correlation that you were like Pooh Bear
because he Pooh was the one that was
full of fluffs okay all right so now
they're getting off into into very
strange stuff so what's funny is maybe
this is new for Neil but this is my
inbox every day okay let's put that
aside what's not funny is that part of
this reaction to Neil Cavuto saying get
vaccinated you know take the politics
out whatever
part of it is a result of coverage that
Neil Cavuto has done and in fact
yesterday he did a story uh about
vaccine mandates triggering protests he
did he he signal boosted again that
there are these wacky people going to
rallies merely to Advocate against
vaccination and the fact that that's
gotten non-stop coverage on Fox News is
part of what has built this monster so
maybe don't cover that Neil particularly
since he supposedly does sort of more of
like a finance based show I mean so I I
I think it's a great thing that Neil
Cavuto is um saying this on Fox it's an
audience that desperately needs to hear
it I'm not surprised that his audience
turned on him listen trumpists what was
the thing that got trumpets to turn on
Trump
at that rally in
I don't even remember was it Georgia was
it Wisconsin a couple months ago when
Trump said I recommend the vaccine and
freedom too but I recommend it that that
completely vile committed trumpist
audience booed Trump so we know that
this is something that will get the
crowd to turn on you uh but you can't
ignore the fact that Neil Cavuto has
also participated in some of this very
same stuff through the story choice that
he's done on his program so that's
what's going on not a big shock that
this is the way that his audience is
reacting what may come as a shock to
some
but not others is new testimony from Dr
Deborah Burks remember Dr Burke's
prominent figure early in the pandemic
response under the Trump Administration
Dr Deborah Burks now says
the Trump Administration could have
prevented 30 to 40 percent of Cova
deaths had Trump taken different actions
and taken the pandemic more seriously
uh Newsweek report Burke's estimates
Trump Administration could have
prevented could 30 to 40 percent of
coveted deaths the Trump
administration's former coronavirus
adviser Dr Deborah Burks estimated that
30 to 40 percent of the 738 thousand
coveted 19 deaths in the U.S could have
been prevented had the White House taken
necessary steps to curb the spread of
the virus in a closed-door testimony
conducted by the house select
coronavirus subcommittee on October 12
and 13. Brooks testified that more than
130
000 American lives could have been saved
in the administ if the administration
promoted mask wearing and social
distancing in the early days of the
pandemic
according to excerpts shared by the
committee Burke said I believe if we had
fully implemented the mask mandates the
reduction in indoor dining the getting
friends and family to understand the
risk of gathering in private homes and
we had increased testing that we
probably could have decreased fatalities
into the 30 percent less to 40 percent
less range asked whether former
president Donald Trump did everything he
could have to handle the pandemic Burke
said no and I've said that to the White
House in general and I believe I was
very clear to the president in specifics
of what I needed him to do we suspected
this but we didn't exactly know how to
quantify it we knew of course we would
have had deaths regardless all countries
have had them but we suspected the
numbers would have been lower had Trump
taken this seriously when Trump was
saying we have 15 cases which will soon
be zero I mean at this point a globally
humiliating statement to have made if he
had been doing something instead of
downplaying it we knew the death count
would have been lower we just didn't
know how much lower the U.S Postal
Service had a plan to mail out masks to
everybody and it got shot down all in
the name of slowing down the postal
service for the election and in not
making it seem as though this was really
a problem and then of course you had the
falsehoods and you had the
misinformation spread during 2020. those
to this day are killing people
people who because of the disinformation
refuse to wear masks people who because
of the disinformation refused to get
themselves vaccinated another report on
this in a Business Insider Trump's White
House ignored advice on kovid that could
have saved over 130 000 lives Burke said
um Burks testified that the 2020
election
distracted Trump from the pandemic so is
it good that Dr Burks is saying this
yeah I guess it's good
was she a purveyor of disinformation
during her time as coronavirus advisor
absolutely and we can go back and forth
and say well she was in a really tough
position or she may have calculated I
need to stay because if I leave this
gets even worse but remember that
completely bizarre interview where she
said Donald Trump is just amazing at
paying attention to the facts and making
decisions on that basis on covet and we
looked at it and we said what the hell
is he talking about here what what on
Earth is this this doesn't make any
sense whatsoever uh and yet she
continued to insist no no no he's doing
now okay later it was intimated it was
said it was suggested you know she was
in a delicate situation there was only
so much he could said but I mean you
guys remember this stuff right and then
I see the disinfectant is there a way we
can do something like that uh AI
injection inside opposing you brought
the light inside the body right you guys
remember all that stuff and Dr Burks I
mean okay she looked confused but she
continued to run interference for that
Administration until it was too late so
great she lets us know that we were
right in what we suspected Trump not
only could have prevented 30 to 40
percent of deaths by the way he could
have easily sailed to re-election by
doing it as I've said many times before
covet was a major drag on Trump's
reelection which ultimately didn't
happen and he lost he lost badly in the
popular vote to Joe Biden but it was
only a few hundred thousand votes in a
few states that electorally handed
Donald Trump a defeat if from day one
Trump had simply said we are gonna we
are really gonna take this as seriously
as anyone
listen to these doctors wear your masks
we've got Trump masks it's so stupid but
if you had done that right away uh he
would have sailed to re-election and we
would have saved many many people so Dr
Burke certainly deserves criticism as
we've said before uh but there is no
question that not only could Trump have
saved people he could be president right
now if he had better handled it let me
know your thoughts we're going to have
more coverage of this on the David
pakman Show Instagram make sure you're
following us there at davidpackman show
you can follow me on Instagram at
david.pakman we will get to the latest
on the January 6th committee after this
short break
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
so on Sunday night this Rolling Stone
story broke written researched by Hunter
Walker
incredible story outlining the degree to
which members of Congress Republican
members of Congress were actually
allegedly involved in the planning of
the January 6th protests that turned
into the Trump riots and a lot of
prominent Republicans were named in that
we we heard the name Marjorie Taylor
green Lauren bobert Madison cawthorne
and others one of the names we heard was
Mo Brooks Mo Brooks is the congressman
who was wearing body armor on January
6th why do you do that unless you
suspect something pretty crazy is going
to happen still not a question that
we've gotten answered well Mo Brooks is
doing something that it tracks with Mo
Brooks and everything we know about him
he's sort of suggesting maybe it was his
staff that was involved in the planning
of what happened on January 6th
completely throwing them under the bus
this is just absolutely fantastic let's
look at an article about this from
Business Insider a con Congressman Mo
Brooks shifted blame onto his staff
after he was accused of helping to
organize the January 6 Capital rally
Mo Brooks shifted blame to his staff
over his alleged role in planning to
stop the steel rally two planners told
Rolling Stone that Congressman Brooks
had been in contact with organizers for
the event Brooks said he had no
involvement in planning it but maybe
maybe his staff had a role I don't know
if my staff did we actually have a tweet
um Melanie zanona who's a Capitol Hill
reporter for CNN tweeted uh
representative Mo Brooks told me he had
no involvement in planning the January
6th rally but said I don't know if my
staff did but if they did I'd be proud
of them for helping to put together a
rally lawful under the First Amendment
at the ellipse to protect protest voter
fraud and election theft
um Brooks was responding to a rolling
stone report that as we told you
identified him as one of the lawmakers
involved in planning the rally outside
the capitol Brooks spoke at the event
telling the audience to start quote
taking down names and kicking ass
he wore body armor as he spoke slate
reported in July shortly afterward as we
now know hundreds of pro-trump
protesters stormed the capital in a
challenge to the certification of Joe
Biden's election Victory so why is why
is Mo Brooks doing this first question
is this an act of desperation by Mo
Brooks throwing his staff under the bust
bus as as his best defense it may be an
act of desperation and what this relates
to is the committee and the
investigation that's going on into
January 6th and the article actually
mentions that the news comes as the
bipartisan Congressional investigation
into the events of January 6 heats up
with the panel moving on Monday to
pursue criminal contempt charges against
Steve Bannon the former Trump aide who
refused to share information about any
role he may have played that day two
people who plan that this is we know
this from the article Monday
two people who plan the rally beforehand
told Rolling Stone that multiple people
involved in planning to stop the steel
rallies communicated with members of
Congress in the run-up to the January
6th event one of whom was Michael was uh
was was Mo Brooks uh the planners also
said they'd been in communication with
uh Congressman Paul gozar Lauren bobert
Madison cawthorne Andy Biggs and Louis
gomert Brooks has been identified as
being involved in the planning of the
wild protest a separate event held on
January 6 that sought to challenge
Biden's election victory in a now
deleted live stream Ali Alexander who
helped organize it said Brooks along
with Gozer and Biggs had come up with
the idea for the protest so there are so
many different ways in which Mo Brooks
is being implicated here but just do a
just do a sniff test do like just a
basic gut check
he wants us to believe
that he had no idea anything might go
down even if his staff were involved in
planning this he didn't know he would be
proud of it but he didn't know but
he just decided to wear body armor on
January 6th just in case
it doesn't pass the sniff test you've
got to just sometimes do a gut check and
say does this is this even is this even
theoretically plausible and it's not and
it's not so we're are there going to be
consequences for someone like Mo Brooks
no probably not Mo Brooks is in a uh
quite a safe seat and it doesn't seem
that his constituents have any real
interest in removing him in November of
2022 that continues to be the trend
where we learn more and more uh and yet
there seems to be very little appetite
from the people who could actually
impose consequences on these folks to
really do anything about it we're going
to talk about that a little more but now
let's go to another Revelation regarding
this Trump Riot committee and as as the
previous discussion mentioned this is a
committee that is really ramping up over
the last seven to ten days that I
believe is part of why you're seeing
increased desperation from these people
including saying I don't know maybe my
staff was involved which would be fine
but it definitely wasn't me I had no
idea but but I did wear body armor none
of these things make any sense
the desperation the completely kind of
unhinged nature of the allegations that
they're making is clearly related to
this committee ramping up let's talk
about that next a new report from CNN at
least five former Trump White House
staffers are talking to the house
January 6 committee this is a report
from CNN's Caitlin Collins filed
yesterday and it contains some very
interesting reports at least five former
Trump Administration staffers have
voluntarily spoken with the house
committee investigating the January 6
attack on the capitol now voluntarily
has a lot wrapped up in it some are
interpreting voluntarily to mean these
are Trump staffers who have turned who
are it's it has weighed on their
conscience what they know and so they
came forward and said I want to speak
that is not not what voluntarily
necessarily means voluntarily means they
weren't subpoenaed
that that's all that we can say for sure
voluntarily means and so it may have
been that these individuals had no real
interest in speaking out about what
happened but they they received a
request to speak to the committee
and their lawyers said or it was implied
or it became understood that you can
decline this but then you're going to
get a subpoena
and a lot of people don't want to get a
subpoena so we can't really read too
much into voluntarily okay those
discussions come as lawyers working for
the committee have also reached out to a
range of other Trump aides to inquire
whether they would be interested in
speaking with the committee voluntarily
without the threat of a subpoena so
there it is the five former staffers who
have had conversations with the
committee have done so with either
members or their staff some believe they
have information worth sharing While
others are hoping to avoid being legally
compelled to talk to the committee very
exactly what we're talking about
Congressman Jamie Raskin who's on the
committee he's a Democrat
he said on CNN yesterday quote I've got
good reason to believe a number of them
are horrified and scandalized by what
took place on January 6th and they want
to do their legal Duty and civic duty by
coming forward to explain exactly what
happened we don't know that to be true
that's Jamie Raskin claiming that we're
going to continue to encourage everybody
who has relevant information to come and
talk the engagement could provide
insight for the committee that's seeking
to learn more about the actions of
former president Trump and supporters
according to five former Trump aides
Council for the committee has emailed or
texted them directly to Ask whether they
are interested in coming to talk to the
Congressional investigators often
looking for context on what happened
inside the West Wing before the
Insurrection on January 6th several
people have voluntarily sat down with
the committee others have declined the
requests or not responded the Outreach
has ranged from junior level staffers to
more seasoned officials the outrage is
the Outreach is not necessarily
necessarily because the committee
believes staffers were involved than
what happened but they want to glean
context on what took place uh period so
one of the real questions here
and unfortunately you know I still
believe and I know it upsets many of you
I don't think there's going to be real
consequences for people regardless of
what the answer here is but one of the
questions that we continue to seek to
answer is to what degree was Trump
involved in planning to what degree did
Donald Trump know that it was going to
get violent to what degree did Donald
Trump encourage or want exactly what
happened to happen we have a variety of
reasons to believe including the fact
that Trump spoke so positively about the
rioters even as the riot was going on on
January 6th in the recorded video
statement that was released we have
every reason to believe that he was
involved and he was enjoying it until or
other than the fact that as he said the
protesters the rioters the
insurrectionists looked low class which
he felt was making him look bad so the
broader context is momentum is building
in terms of the committee
we don't know whether people speaking to
the committee are really turning on
Trump but I still don't think this is
going to lead to the types of
consequences you and I would like to see
I know it upsets many of you I know
there are people in the audience who
when I say this they write to me and say
David you're part of the problem saying
there won't be consequences is likely to
make that happen it's a self-fulfilling
prophecy I reject that completely what I
say will have no bearing on whether
there are consequences there are going
to be no real consequences for the top
people so we're talking about Trump
we're talking about Mark Meadows we're
talking about members of Congress like
Mo Brooks Lauren bobert Marjorie Taylor
green Louis Gomer Etc there may be you
know a sort of mild public shaming of
some kind Republicans will of course
claim it's all bogus that none of it is
deserved that it's all a Witch Hunt
there will be slaps on the wrist for
most of the actual insurrection just
remember this 300 to 400 of these cases
that are now pending there will be some
slaps on the wrist some people will get
slightly more serious sentences we've
seen a couple of them handed out a few
years Trump's political career may just
kind of Peter out
or he'll end up president again which is
really scary uh and at the end of the
day this is not going to so damage Trump
that the potential to be president again
will be eliminated it may just not
happen it may deflate Trump if this gets
really bad if what we learn is really
damaging it may deflate trump it may
hurt Republicans in 2022 which itself
uh functions to discourage Donald Trump
from running in 2024 I hope I'm wrong I
hope that there are real consequences
and that they are significant Etc
uh but it is certainly not seeming
likely to me at this point in time if
you now now here's who I want to hear
from if you just want to say David stop
repeating that skip it don't email me I
get those emails all the time
if you want to explain to me the actual
path for how it will happen and who will
hold the members of Congress allegedly
evolved accountable White House staff
allegedly involved accountable Trump
accountable explain to me the sequence
of events and how it will happen I don't
see it but if you understand a path
forward on that I do want to hear from
you you can email info davidpackman.com
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show all right
we're going to have a very instructive
segment here on the concept of
stochastic terrorism stochastic
terrorism is something we've talked
about many times before the idea is that
if you have a large enough audience and
you put out radical ideas you allude to
drastic action or violence that if your
audience is big enough it starts to
become statistically likely that someone
in that audience is going to take what
you say and turn it into real world
violence one example is a Glenn back
years ago on his old program right-wing
host Glenn Beck would constantly be
ranting about the tides Foundation the
tides foundation and his audience was
big enough that eventually he actually
convinced the guy to go and drive to the
town's Tides foundation with the goal of
shooting it up the guy was actually
stopped I believe it was by California
Highway Patrol on his way and said yeah
Glenn Beck radicalized me and that's why
you know we got to stop what these
people are doing
um one such organization that is doing
this in a in a sense is this
organization Turning Point USA whose
most prominent sort of spokesperson is a
guy named Charlie Kirk
Charlie Kirk does not uh directly
advocate for violence and even in the
clip I'm playing for you he denounces
someone in the audience who talks about
using guns to kill these people but what
you have to understand is when you run a
group like this and you do event after
event with extremely radical ideas where
you are telling the audience the
Democrats the left whatever these are
socialists these are communists these
are oppressors these are all these
different things these are all lies by
the way that are being told of course
you are going to start radicalizing
people in the audience who are
eventually going to say well I should
really do something about it some of
those people will do something about it
by voting some of them will do something
about it by bullying people on the
internet and unfortunately some
percentage uh of the disproportionately
gun owning people in the following base
of Charlie Kirk in Turning Point USA may
turn to violence and that's exactly what
we have an example of right here we are
going to play a clip of an audience
member who loves Charlie Kirk who says
hey when can we use our guns to kill
these people it's not a euphemism
it's not a metaphor he literally is
saying at a certain point like when can
we start shooting these people and what
I want you to listen to is when Charlie
Kirk denounces it he doesn't denounce it
because he's morally against shooting
political opponents maybe he is but he
doesn't say it he denounces it because
he says that would be playing into what
the left wants and it would give them
justification to be even more radical
that's why Charlie Kirk denounces it
look that this is everything that is
wrong with the American right wing right
now let's take a listen let's take a
look
[Applause]
you ready yeah you're brave you're brave
for what you say and the fact that
you've seen up there and say it and I
appreciate it I think we all appreciate
it actually because there's not a lot of
people so big Charlie Kirk fan calling
him Brave what Charlie Kirk does and
says is is just it's silly pablum but
this guy says it's Brave okay
[Applause]
so prepare yourself
at this point we're living under a
corporate and medical fascism now that's
not that's not true okay let's go this
is tyranny
when do we get to use the guns
no and I I I'm not that's not a joke now
a lot of the crowd cheers and this guy
says it's not a metaphor he's saying it
literally okay I'm
literally Where's the Line how many
elections are they gonna steal before we
kill these people so no I I I no hold on
I'm no stop hold on now I'm going to
denounce that I'm going to tell you why
okay so I'm gonna denounce that and I'm
going to tell you what tell us Charlie
is it because it's wrong to do that
because you're playing into all their
plans
[Laughter]
no killing them with guns would play
right into their plans so we we
shouldn't do that
what about it being completely wrong and
immoral and Criminal
no no it would play into their hands
they're trying to make you do this
that's okay just hear me out
you started with the compliment so at
least give me a little bit
they are trying to provoke you and
everyone here they are trying to make
you do something that will be violent
that will justify a takeover of your
freedoms and Liberties the likes of
which we have never seen we are close to
have hold on we are close to have
momentum to be able to get this country
back on a trajectory using the peaceful
means that we have at us so to answer
your question and I just think it's you
know overly blunt we have to be the ones
that do not play into the violent aims
and Ambitions of the other side they
fear let me say this very clearly they
fear us this this is a uh this is a
verbal trapeze artist it's it's a
contortion
to use federal Force against us and I
know that people get fired up we are
living under fascism we are living under
this tyranny no we're not I think for a
second that they're not wanting you to
all of a sudden get that next level
where they're gonna say okay we need
patriarch 2.0 if you think that you know
Waco is bad what do you see what they
want to do next what I'm saying is that
we have a very fragile balance right now
at our current time where we must
exhaust every single peaceful mean
possible I will say this Idaho has not
even started to exercise the peaceful
means of State sovereignty against the
federal government not even close I'll
give you five things Idaho could do
right now the governor of Idaho could
sign an executive okay
so Charlie Kirk is clearly smart enough
not to encourage he knows if he goes you
know what you're right we should just go
and kill these people with guns let's
kill our political opponents with guns
he has no choice but to denounce it
which he did and to the extent that he
deserves credit for that okay he
denounced it but he's not saying don't
go and kill people with guns because
it's morally wrong he's not saying don't
go and kill people with guns because
that's actually the problem in the
United States that you know I talk about
we have a unique cultural problem in the
U.S where there are people
that sea guns as a solution to political
problems and to interpersonal problems
this guy's the perfect example he's
saying listen they stole an election
which they didn't we're now under
fascism which we're not so we should go
and we should solve those problems by
killing people shoot them dead with guns
this isn't this is the prototypical
American that embodies the cultural
problem we have with guns in the United
States Charlie's not saying that's not
what gun should be used for he's not
saying it's morally wrong he's not
saying that's criminal he's just saying
it would backfire it would play into it
would justify them becoming even more
fascistic in fact Charlie agrees with
the guy and saying we are living under
fascism so even what the guy identifies
as a problem Charlie agrees with and
says we are living under fascism but the
problem is if we go out and kill them
with guns
not that it's wrong not that it's
immoral
it'll just justify even more of their
fascism uh now there's another
interpretation of Charlie Kirk's answer
and this this one is the cynical one
this is the grifty interpretation which
is Charlie Kirk doesn't really believe
any of what he's selling okay he doesn't
really want to change anything he
doesn't want real action he doesn't want
resolution he wants to be perpetually on
the edge of boiling over and continue
holding these events so that the
business model perpetuates itself and
nothing really like if you really solve
the problem right whatever whatever
means you use as he says no no no we're
gonna we're gonna go do the school
boards and then we're gonna do this
we're going to do that then we're going
to solve it well then there's no more
Turning Point USA there's no more angry
people going to these events and saying
we got to fix the fascism if you fix the
fascism there's no more people who will
show up and say Charlie help us fix the
fascism because you've dealt with it so
the other cynical interpretation of
Charlie denouncing the shooting people
dead with guns is now then that'll hurt
my events
uh but the problem is people here
there is fascism and they don't hear
Charlie say it's wrong to shoot people
they just hear him say Well it would it
wouldn't be productive towards our cause
and then it has that stochastic
terrorist effect then think about it
this guy who asked the question said he
thinks Charlie Kirk is smart and he
thinks Charlie Kirk is brave and he
wants to shoot his political opponents
over non-existent medical Fascism and
not non-existent election theft and he's
not being told that it's wrong he's just
being told it wouldn't be good strategy
well he might just disagree on strategy
or maybe someone else in the audience
does now probably the FBI should have a
look at the guy who asked the question
does that guy own guns I would assume
almost certainly yes what's going on
with him emotionally is he stable is he
likely to do something that's someone
who in all seriousness should be on the
radar of authorities of law enforcement
authorities when they tell you what they
want to do we should listen to them and
this guy is telling us exactly what he
wants to do he wants to solve problems
he wrongly believes to exist like that
of a stolen election or medical fascism
by shooting people dead
law enforcement should listen to that
and then they should investigate it we
have been talking I'm not going to spend
a lot of time on this next story but I
do want to follow up because people ask
me David what's going on with those
complaints against Marjorie Taylor green
we've said before radical trumpist
republican congresswoman Marjorie Taylor
green has been accused and it has been
investigated there has been an
investigation going on uh as to whether
she illegally spent campaign funds there
is unaccounted for campaign money there
are now two different ethics complaints
that we have learned about that accuse
Marjorie Taylor Greene of unethical and
illegal campaign spending Progressive
Watchdog group and citizens united filed
two ethics complaints against Marjorie
Taylor green
She's accused of unethical and illegal
spending by her save America stop
socialism leadership pack one complaint
was filed with the House's ethics body
which has already fined her three times
for not wearing a mask
um she is facing these accusations
according to two ethics complaints the
group filed a complaint with both the
FEC
and the office of congressional ethics
both of which focus on a recent ad where
she urges supporters to call members of
Congress and ask them to oppose the one
trillion dollar infrastructure bill
passed by the Senate last month
um the group's FEC complaint alleges
that greens save America stops socialism
leadership pack made an unreported
in-kind contribution to her own campaign
by running a nearly identical version of
the ad on oan and that the contribution
well exceeded the five thousand dollar
limit legally permitted many members of
Congress have so-called leadership packs
which are nominally for raising money
for other candidates but they have
become slush funds by ethics Advocates
so that's one complaint meanwhile the
complaint with the house ethics body
says she improperly used her campaign
and Leadership pack to conduct official
house activities because the ad
constitutes a Grassroots lobbying
campaign to oppose legislation you know
I'm glad that this is going on I really
am and like of course we know that
Marjorie Taylor green is doing sketchy
stuff with campaign funding and and
various political uh sources of money
but is there ever really going to be
punishment I mean remember we covered
the story of Marjorie Taylor green
taking two Homestead exemptions making
two Homestead declarations which is not
legal in Georgia she did she has it on
two properties whatever happened with it
nothing nothing that I was able to find
as of this morning ethics complaints
what comes of those other than the
ethics office
filing it I mean I I really don't know
now technically
these complaints could lead to expulsion
basically never happens like expulsions
from the house not related to the Civil
War I believe it's you know it's under
five that has I think it might be two or
three that have ever happened so
unfortunately even though the list of
concerns about the behavior of Marjorie
Taylor green ethically and legally
continues to rise the real solution is
voting her out she's in a very red
District it doesn't look like it's going
to happen it's horrifying I I'm with you
it's completely dystopian but it is just
not looking good and the best path
forward is uh to continue maybe growing
Democratic control of the house in 2022
as unlikely as that might seem and what
can be done censure she's already been
stripped of committee assignments I
really don't know it's actually one of
the most frustrating aspects of American
government right now that there seems to
be very little in the way of serious
ways to hold people accountable we have
a voicemail number that number is 2192
David P I'm gonna play this is a really
sad voicemail this is a longer voicemail
than I would normally play
but the reason I'm playing it is I want
to show you how far reaching the being
victimized by disinformation can be this
is a caller who has been completely
victimized by disinformation and he's
fallen for a lot of really wacky things
let's listen
hey David I listened to your clips on
YouTube just to see what you're talking
about and uh okay vmle degree disagree
with basically everything you say when
it comes to vaccination
um I really don't understand how
something that's not even really
properly FDA approved has known side
effects including gas mileage carditis
including all kinds of Adverse Events
which is well documented
uh how can the left be so so aggressive
in their stance on vaccination and uh
like I said I'm just a concerned parent
concerned citizen something that I don't
really uh plan on partaking in I will
feel like these announces and deny it I
think it's uh it goes against everything
that this country is based upon
fundamentally that we allow corporations
that basically own this place to dictate
what is injected into our bodies in
order to to hold a job to create
Commerce to transact to travel
um and I never I never been much of a
political person not really political
standing I'm just concerned about my
health and wellness and I really have a
big problem with corporations and people
that are in the political sphere
politicizing Health and Wellness
and I just I'm curious why why don't you
have somebody on your show who's
actually well informed on the science
the time behind what's in these
injections I mean there's documented
proof coming out about all kinds of
parasites in the injections uh graphene
oxide all kinds of different things and
I'm sure you could have somebody on
who's very well versed in these things
and you can have a rational discourse
about what's actually going on instead
of uh shaming people for not partaking
in the science experiment all right
thank you so much
so as you can see this is someone who's
been victimized in many many ways and
they just believe all sorts of things
that aren't true now let's just talk I
mean like one two three four five six
seven so I was taking notes as he spoke
so he said that the vaccine is not
actually approved so there are three
vaccines approved by emergency use
authorization and the Pfizer vaccine is
fully approved so that's not true he
said that the vaccines are leading to
countless deaths
um we after our last segment I got a few
emails ended further research there are
three deaths that are being investigated
as to whether
vaccine caused myocarditis which led to
death it's being investigated it's being
investigated okay so compared to the
number of deaths from covet and of
course the relative risk from the
vaccine it's close to zero
um he said that uh corporations are
dictating what you must have injected uh
I'm not aware of that I'm aware of
Corporations saying if you want to make
the decision to work here here are our
requirements and different corporations
have required different vaccines for
decades that's not anything new
um he said he's just concerned about
health for his family and himself well
the best way to stay healthy when it
comes to covet is to get vaccinated he
said I could have a well-informed guest
on to talk about the science I have
we've had immunologists
um uh Isaac bogosh a doctor and we've
had arguably the top virologist in the
country Vincent rack and yellow those
are the experts he said that the vaccine
has parasites inside of it that's not
true and then just to pick one to talk a
little bit more about he said the
vaccines have graphene oxide in them
this came from so just to tell you where
that came from
a professor in Spain
claimed that there were tests done of a
vial of the vaccine and what was
supposedly a dose of the Pfizer vaccine
supposedly has graphene oxide in it now
it's been fact checked there's no
evidence that there's graphene oxide in
the vaccine a Pfizer has denied it it's
not listed on the list of ingredients
and it's not actually been demonstrated
that this guy even analyzed an actual
vial of the Pfizer vaccine that's where
it comes from and so in just a minute
this this goes to what Sam Harris
recently said about sometimes the
futility of debating these folks in a
minute and 49 second voicemail he was
able to start seven what Sam Harris
would refer to as small fires which now
we would be in a position to have to put
out each of them one by one and if you
fail to put out all seven convincingly
it may actually do damage further damage
so it's uh agree or disagree with Sam
Harris his assessment of the the sort of
difficulty of arguing with these people
very very well stated and this is just
one example we've got a great bonus show
for you today sign up on my website grab
a membership at joinpakman.com and then
we'll see you on the bonus show
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors disco delivers
affordable science-backed skin care
treatments to your home the Disco
Starter Set helps guys fight oily skin
and razor burn and keeps your skin
hydrated I've had great results with it
you'll get 30 off at letsdisco.com
Pacman the link is down below